everybody has a prenup either the
government makes one or you make one
yourself um and I have always been
someone that thinks very negatively
towards prenups my husband and I when we
were married granted we were broke but
we always felt that the word divorce was
out of the question and that if you're
even considering a prenup then you're
opening yourself up to the possibility
of a divorce so I wanted your opinion as
a Christian as somebody who is wealthy
what is your uh perspective on I would
just say whoever you're listening to is
only looking at the advice they're
giving through a singular lens our
approach is we believe that personal
finance is 80% behavior and we've proven
that it's not about math and it's not
about that stuff so uh our approach is
is that the prenup actually could end up
uh stunting your growth because you're
not all in on working together